morgen jährt sich die
loveparade-katastrophe zum zehnten mal
bereits heute abend wird der opfer
gedacht mit einer nacht der lichter bei
mir im studio ist jetzt michael
engelberg du hast die tragödie von
anfang an verfolgt also seit zehn jahren
was löst dieses traurige jubiläum bei
dir aus also ich muss sagen das war
wirklich auch für mich als reporter der
schwärzeste tag es war ganz ganz
schlimmes kurz zum hintergrund wir waren
mit sehr vielen reportern damals vor ort
wir haben selbst eine eine runde über
diese dieses gelände am bahnhof am
güterbahnhof in duisburg gedreht es war
für uns nichts erkennbar wo irgendwie
engstellen zu sehen sind
dann habe ich ein interview mit dem
innenminister mit dem damaligen minister
geführt er sagte es sei alles in ordnung
dann habe ich mit einem mitarbeiter der
malteser gesprochen er sagte mir dass
alles wirklich ist läuft hervorragend
und dann bekam ich einen anruf unseres
kollegen frank schneider und explodierte
förmlich an sagte hier ist eine
katastrophe passiert hier liegen tote
und ich konnte mir das gar nicht
erklären und dann habe ich sofort
geschaltet habe mit dem malteser
pressesprecher gesprochen und dann
nahmen die ganze katastrophe seinen lauf
und ich muss sagen es bewegt mich auch
bis heute noch verständlicher weise wir
wollen noch einmal zurückblicken eben
auf den 24 juli 2010 dem tag der
tragödie
diese bilder haben die welt schockiert
24 juli 2010 starben 21 menschen
qualvoll auf der loveparade hunderte
werden verletzt
und auch jahre später kämpfen tausende
noch immer mit der schrecklichen
erinnerung an die größte massenpanik bei
einer veranstaltung die es je in
deutschland gab der 24 juli 2010 war ein
hochsommertag im alten güterbahnhof in
duisburg drängen am nachmittag
hunderttausende auf einen tunnel zu den
tunnel der der einzige ein und ausgang
zu diesem unglücks event ist den tunnel
der zur falschen zeit geschlossen wird
wo hereinströmende und heim wollen sich
plötzlich gegenseitig den weg versperren
und die absperrungen zur todesfalle
werden viel zu wenige schlecht
ausgestattete ordner und polizei treffen
im kompetenzwirrwarr die falschen
entscheidungen müssen dem wahnsinn
machtlos zusehen
[Applaus]
nur wenige meter entfernt von der stelle
wo das unfassbare passierte erinnert
heute ein denkmal an die 21 toten vom 24
juli 2010 trotz der offensichtlichen
planungsfehler konnte nie ein schuldiger
gefunden werden
im mai 2020 hat das landgericht duisburg
den prozess gegen die organisatoren
eingestellt nach 184 verhandlungstagen
ohne urteil
die begründung des gerichts zu
erwartende einschränkungen wegen corona
und die verjährung des tötungsvorwurf ja
wirklich heftige bilder bei einem studio
ist immer noch michael engelberg du
konntest auch in der ganzen zeit mit
vielen angehörigen sprechen auch jetzt
gleich wird es mit einer mutter sprechen
die er vor zehn jahren ihren sohn
verloren hat
das ist richtig wir sprechen jetzt mit
gabi müller gabi müller hat vor zehn
jahren ihren sohn christian bei der
loveparade verloren grünamt formula
erstmal herzlichen dank dass sie sich
und so einen schweren abend auch noch
zur verfügung stellen mit uns zu
sprechen von müller
sie stehen jetzt an der treppe an der
rampe wo ihr sohn vor zehn jahren das
leben verloren hat welcher welche
gefühle löst das in ihnen aus an dem ort
des geschehens zu sein wo sie einen sohn
verloren hat
traurigkeit beruht ganz gemischte
gefühle können sie mal so ein bisschen
beschreiben wir haben in den zehn jahren
viel durchgemacht wie wie ist es für sie
damit zu leben es gibt kein urteil
die sachen sind nicht völlig aufgeklärt
was macht so ein tag mit ihm ja es ist
einfach ganz schlimm das ist also ich
würde sagen das ist für mich der zehnte
jahrestag ist nach dem unglück mit der
schlimmste können sie das ein bisschen
beschreiben
ja ich sag 2010 haben wir unseren sohn
verloren
das war der schlimmste tag in unserem
leben
ja und dann was alles danach kamen aber
das wissen wir ja und jetzt nach zehn
jahren ja also ich ganz gefühlsmäßig
kann ich sie beschreiben was da in einem
vor sich geht
man könnte meinen man könnte schreien
ist ja es ist fürchterlich
jetzt ist der prozess ohne urteil zu
ende gegangen wir haben in den letzten
zehn jahren wirklich sehr sehr oft
miteinander gesprochen
wir standen zusammen am grab ihres
sohnes beschreiben sie uns christian mal
ein wenig was war das für ein junge der
eigentlich mit seinen kumpels an diesem
tag eigentlich nur feiern wollte ja der
wollte nur feiern und spaß haben
vorher war ja noch die wm da waren sie
auch immer unterwegs ja und das sollte
so für ihn der abschluss seien jetzt für
die nächste zeit erst mal weil er gesagt
hat die party nehme ich doch mit
das ist vielleicht das letzte mal in
duisburg oder überhaupt im ruhrgebiet
und einmal muss man das erlebt haben ja
und so sind sie ja dann auch los gezogen
sie wollten einfach nur spaß haben der
spaß endet in einer tragödie wonach
haben sie in den letzten zehn jahren
worauf haben sie gehofft wonach haben
sie sich gesehnt mit dem ende was wir
jetzt alle kennen ja aufklärung und
gerechtigkeit das war unser ziel weil
ich sage für 21 tote menschen und über
500 verletzte gibt es keine gerechte
strafe und es geht auch nicht um
strafmaß oder was das wollten wir ja
alle gar nicht es ging um aufklärung und
gerechtigkeit vielen da gab müller dass
sie sich die zeit genommen haben an so
einem schwierigen tag mit uns darüber zu
sprechen